[Music]
how many of you have completed my plank
challenge previously so a lot of you
have requested for a new plank challenge
here's what we're going to do we're
going to complete this five-minute plank
challenge and I want you to let me know
if you can complete this entire workout
or how long did you manage to hold a
plank let me know in the comments below
there will be ten exercises and each
exercise will be for 30 seconds long and
we will move on to the next workout
without any break okay we all know that
plank it's a really good cold workout it
works on your upper body and also your
legs so let's get ready and let's do
this
[Music]
okay so just give me your best shot we
will start with a basic plank to begin
with okay so get down onto the mat
remember that your shoulders should
always be should width apart elbows
directly underneath your shoulder okay
keep your body flat and just hold this
pose for 30 seconds that's your first
plank exercise okay so remember but do
not Pike us do not arch your lower back
give me a nice solid flat back and you
are halfway there 14 more seconds 10
more seconds
if you feel your arms shaking if you
feel cross shaking that is absolutely
fine that means you're engaging your
muscles okay the second plank will be
playing across so I want you to rock
your body back and forward okay simple
forward and back so plank rock good
forward and back type in and get your
core you are tightening really suck your
belly in squeeze your butt everything
should be tight for your shoulders and
just relax your upper body and keep
Rocking
very good sometimes minimal movement is
the best okay
next plank dig so just dip side to side
good
laughs and right lower your hips as low
as you can dip and you should feel your
obliques working more for this plank
very nice keep going keep dipping left
and right good
this is exercise number three and the
next one will be plank lick tap okay so
stand open up in out and in good
alternate each side very good
out and in just hold it do your apps you
should start to burn slightly now you
keep going left and right tap it keep
your back and your body straight five
more seconds tap in and out and keep
tapping and next will be arms okay so
reach tap rich taps this is a little bit
more challenging okay so reach out and
tap good keep going tap to the side very
good how are you doing still surviving
keep going and the next plank will be
sprinter plank okay we want to get up
onto your palms keep going
remember to breathe in alright up and
it's like a sprinter like a mountain
climber basically okay so this is going
to add a little bit more cardio to your
routine and your challenge good so bring
your knees in point your toes and sprint
halfway there very good
whoa see your heart rate raising and
feel your core muscles working all right
holy there thanks jack so keep your
upper body strong and just jack in and
out very good it's still on your cardio
nice remember to keep your back as flat
as you can more than halfway there
10 seconds left keep going five seconds
last four and we want to go for plank up
down let's go down and you [ __ ] up good
down and push it up alternate good down
and up
stay strong stay with me you are almost
there okay you're almost four minutes in
to the workout good stay strong push up
and down up and down up down and push up
and just hold it here okay let's go for
spider-man plank so bring it in
crunch it to the side okay bring your
knee to your elbow good feel the side of
your abs working very good so out and
keep going you have under one minute and
the final will be a plank cross keep
going and just hold it there
cross it over good last 30 seconds do
not stop now I know how your house
probably dying your core is shaking but
you got this last 15 more seconds keep
crossing crossover knee to elbow and you
will get a break ah come on
my arms are getting weaker
and weekend and just relax
well done that was your five minutes
plank challenge let me know if you
actually completed the entire challenge
if to begin with you can only hold a
plank for two minutes that's all right
keep doing this workout right at the end
of your workout session and you will
slowly progress and improve okay this is
a really good core workout minimal
movement very little movement but you
will really target those muscles so
challenge your friend take your friend
in the comments below get them to do
this plank challenge with you and see
who did better give this video a thumbs
up share this video and subscribe to my
youtube channel for a lot more workout
challenges workout videos fitness tips
and also delicious and healthy recipes
don't forget to turn on your
notification button so that you will get
notified every time I share a new video
all the best and keep planking